Great, so
what's the efficiency of this algorithm?
Well, we had to go through pretty
much the whole array a lot of times.
Here's roughly what we did.
Overall we had to do four or
n -1 iterations, and
at each step we did n- 1 comparisons.
So n- 1 comparisons for and n- 1
iterations gives us something like this.
We can use a little algebra to
figure out what this simplifies to.
And we get something
that looks like this.
Again, don't worry too much
if you can't do the algebra.
The minus one isn't changing much for
us so
you could always just do n
times n equals n squared.
Thus, we really don't need
this minus -2n+1 bit.
We can get rid of it and
that leaves us with this is
efficiency big o of n squared.
Actually there's a way we could have
saved ourselves some time with this
algorithm.
If you noticed each time we went
through the array we compared the last
few values even though we really
didn't need to after a while.
It made sense to compare 7 and
8 when we were bubbling up 7.
But when we were bubbling up
some of the lower numbers
this comparison didn't
really change anything.
The most common version of Bubble Sort
actually leaves out this step
every time of comparing the last few
when you really don't need to do that.
It assumes that after the first
iteration you know that eight
is in the right place.
So you don't need to check it
against anything else later.
Again this will save us some time but
it's not going to change our overall
run time of big O of n squared.
I have a couple quick notes for
you okay.
So we understand by the worst case and
the average case are going
to be big O of n squared.
However, the best case is
actually going to be big O of n.
The best case would either be that the
array was already sorted in which we can
just go through it once see that sorted
and not have to do anything else or if
there's only one number that needs to be
bubbled up to a new place in the array.
And one last thing, we didn't have to
use anything extra to do our sort.
We had no extra arrays, no extra
data structures, nothing like that.
Bubble Sort is a great example of
an in-place sorting algorithm,
so the space complexity is constant.
Meaning we didn't need any extra arrays
or data structures in the whole process.